un 6000 habitants entre boss et Orléan
et des nitrates et des pesticides dans
son eau qu'il faut donc filtrer à grand
frais il était donc évident pour la
commune d'éviter de rajouter de la
pollution à la pollution et depuis 2009
elle a réduit considérablement l'usage
des pesticides sur ces 35 hectares
d'espace vert et les a même éliminé
complètement sur une partie certifié
zéro pesticide à la place des herbicides
par exemple jardinier utilise notamment
le paayage tout l'intérêt c'est
d'empêcher la prélevée des herbes
d'éviter donc de positionner des
herbicides celui-ci va maintenir une
fraîcheur au sol et au fil du temps va
se décomposer et va ramener de la
matière organique ce qui va permettre de
de recréer une vie microbienne qui est
indispensable au sol et qui va
bénéficier aux plantes dans ce quartier
résidentiel fini les pelouses interdites
au public et gavé de chimie les allées
sont désherbées par le passage des
piétons tout simplement et le reste est
devenu une superbe prairie naturelle le
but c'est de Tourre un peu moins
fréquemment et ce qui nous ce qui nous
permet maintenant de de découvrir et de
maintenir la flore naturelle et au point
d'aller d'avoir découvert une plusieurs
types d'orchidées qu'on ne qu'on ne
voyait pas auparavant parce qu'on on
tondait trop souvent justement et
aujourd'hui l'aspect est très naturel et
convient convient parfaitement aux
habitants du quartier mais il y a 15 ans
quand les jardiniers de la ville ont
commencé à changer de pratique ils ont
dû faire face aux interpellations d'une
partie des habitants je pense qu' une
question de génération il y a des
habitudes qui étaient prises par
notamment les anciens avec lespendag
massif parfois de de produits la
nouvelle génération change et puis inré
on a une vraie action d'éducation
l'environnement vers les plus jeunes
pour faire partager ces pratiques
nouvelles la commune d'Ingré a pu
compter sur l'aide du Conseil régional
on sait qu'aujourd'hui ces pesticides
portent largement atteinte à notre
environnement et bien faire en sorte que
dans les villes et les villages on
prenne ça en compte et qu'on développe
de très beaux espaces paysagers de très
beaux espaces de de d'ornement et cetera
en utilisant des des techniques qui sont
souvent des techniques traditionnelles
d'ailleurs mais qui sont des techniques
qui préservent notre environnement et
c'est la
cent qui a piloté ce changement de cap
pour les communes petite ampleur sachant
que
92,7% des pesticides ce sont les
agriculteurs qui les utilisent mais par
contre sur des territoires comme ceux
comme les communes notamment bien ça
incite d'autres acteurs les agriculteurs
par exemple réduireusage des pesticides
pour l' 117 communes de la Région Centre
on éliminé d'une partie ou de la
totalité de leur territoire ces
pesticides que l'agriculture est censé
éliminer à son tour de moitié dans les
prochaines
années